could you both right now could you do
Will and Grace could you do wings with
the workload and and all that could you
do it right now I think this the dirty
secret of sitcom is that it's not that
many hours a week right it's the writers
that work hard it's the people building
the sets the reboot just ended a couple
of years ago I mean that is a kind of
Sprint for me that's a fabulous Sprint
whereas I think doing an hour-long show
out of town sitcoms to me kind of make
me a little nervous for me it was just
like oh my I remember they threw like
this little monologue at me and they go
hey and right before we went on you're
gonna do this like yeah I go what the f
I I can't and I remember my dad was in
the audience and I'm and I I struggle I
need to like let it sink in and it was
really nerve-wracking but you didn't
feel that way I think that that you know
For Better or Worse that's a facility
that I have that or at least had that
that I I loved that challenge